[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi à 18 avril
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition le soleil est de retour dans le
département des températures estivales
dont profitent largement les yvelinois
avec balades et activités de plein air
peut être une bonne nouvelle aussi pour
les commerçants près des gares qui
subissaient les conséquences de la grève
dans les transports
reportage à suivre les républicains des
yvelines devront désigner leur président
en octobre une élection qui révèle
quelques divergences au sein de la
fédération ait deux camps se sont
constitués l'un d'eux autour notamment
de la conseillère régionale alexandra
dublanche candidate pour le scrutin
elle nous recevons l'un de ses
principaux soutiens pascal thévenot
maire de vélizy villacoublay
enfin une population carcérale frôlant
les 200 % en ile-de-france des cellules
insalubres les conditions de vie en
prison sont souvent dénoncé un colloque
sur le sujet se tient ce vendredi à lui
vs qu est il est organisé par des
étudiants en droit
la grève d'abord et les perturbations
qui se poursuivent encore demain jeudi a
la sncf les cheminots mène un mouvement
perlé pour s'opposer à la réforme
ferroviaire du gouvernement
le texte a été largement adopté hier en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
à 4 154 voix contre dent pour 454 voix
pour et 80 contre le trafic sera encore
très perturbé ce jeudi sur les réseaux
des transports en ile de france à saint
quentin en yvelines ce sera encore plus
perturbée par rapport à aujourd'hui
ah c'est un train sur trois sur le rer c
1 train sur 4 pour la ligne l du
transilien enfin c'est un train sur
trois pour la ligne u pour connaître les
dernières informations et consulter les
horaires de votre un rendez vous sur le
site du transilien et si vous devez
attendre justement votre train ou
emprunter des alternatives vous serez au
moins sous le soleil le beau temps
pourrait augmenter la fréquentation des
commerces autour des gares et les
boutiques vont elles retrouvé le sourire
après les conséquences négatives de la
grève
c'est la question posée par michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas dans le riz
garde plaisir grignon neuf trains au
départ de plaisir grignon pour paris
montparnasse entre 6h30 et 10h30
aucune circulation sur la ligne n en
direction de mantes la jolie
heureusement les conséquences de la
mobilisation sociale sont atténuées par
le ciel bleu et le retour de
températures élevées
les commerçants du quartier en profitent
notamment cette boulangerie avec les
produits rafraîchissant ça joue sur les
ouvriers du matin par exemple ça veut
dire que tout ce qui est le pain au
chocolat du matin la baguette du midi
tout est différé les gens prennent pas
le temps de sortir pour pour rattraper
je vais effectivement ça le beau temps
c'est radical à chaque fois qu'il ya un
petit rayon de soleil les gens sortent
profite de la terrasse alain petit café
est une boisson fraîche donc ça compense
le rotrou cette épicerie du quartier
plaisir grignon perd entre 15 et 20 % de
sa clientèle depuis le début de la grève
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours il pense
compenser cet effet négatif sur son
commerce la semaine dernière par de
beautor est arrivé grève
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de clients
n'étaient pas mariés notre avis mardi
des grèves ça aurait beaucoup de mal
by pas beaucoup de la journée hélas
hélas ça va un petit peu ça commence à
bouger
d'autres commerçants ne ressentent
aucune différence ils profitent même des
alternatives proposées à la gare de
plaisir grignon avec les réseaux de bus
le retour du beau temps vous l'avez vu
satisfait certains commerçants près des
gares il en est de même pour les
yvelinois de manière générale depuis
hier le soleil rayonne sur l'ensemble du
département et quelques comportements
estivaux refont leur apparition du
farniente ou encore des activités en
extérieur regarder à ce sujet de patrick
jacques de dixmude et marion de tak
dans la matinée le thermomètre affichait
déjà 20 degrés après la morosité de
l'hiver ce temps estival a ravi les
yvelinois dans les parcs petits et
grands profitent de ces vacances
ensoleillées
ce que j'aime bien faire quand il ya du
soleil c'est plutôt sortir et jouer au
ballon
au faire de la balançoire dans mon
jardin est aussi regarder les animaux
qui se promène dans la nature le
programme des prochains jours c'est
peut-être une escapade au bord de la mer
voilà et se balader voit la pensée arias
se vider l'esprit profiter juste du
soleil la chaleur on a quand même eu un
hiver un peu
dure un peu long mais là ça nous a fait
du bien on vient ici le parc est
agréable il ya de l'espace pour le grand
les petits y sont ils sont heureux les
rayons du soleil font du bien au moral
mais aussi aux fleurs dans son jardin en
cpt2 faut cultiver une centaine de
plantes différentes
hélas les bananiers votre connaissance
sont pas très beau parce qu'on les a
couverts pendant pendant quatre mois
d'hiver et là ça commence ici un mois
venez voir les défenses ça va monter
jusqu'à 2 m chaque année la passionnée
de jardinage ouvre son jardin aux
curieux le retour du soleil est une
aubaine on est bien en vie on est
content mais on reste la journée dans le
jardin on regarde les pousse à regarder
les semis qui sortent
on est content qu'on voit que ça a servi
tour rubis la verdure près le reprenne
le chemin
selon météo france le soleil devrait
encore brillé toute la semaine il y a
comme un air d'été qui souffle sur les
yvelines pour le plus grand bonheur de
ses habitants dans l'actualité également
ce déplacement ministériel à plaisir la
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes marlène
schiappa s'est rendu à la maison des
familles flora tristan cet après midi à
la rencontre des membres de
l'association mille et un mot c'est une
association dont elle est devenue
marraine une structure qui accompagne
les parents dont l'apprentissage du
langage à leurs enfants avant l'entrée
en école maternelle elle nous
détaillerons cette visite dans le
journal de demain jeudi est la france
lui a rendu un hommage national sans cyr
l'école va baptiser l'une de ses
nouvelles artères au nom d'arnaud
beltrame ce boulevard colonel arnaud
beltrame se situera dans la zac renard
en cours d'achèvement et les élus ont
décidé à l'unanimité lors du dernier
conseil municipal un geste plein de
symboles en mémoire du gendarme tué lors
de l'attaqué terroriste de trèbes
il avait suivi les cours de classe
préparatoire au lycée militaire de saint
cyr avant d'intégrer l armée de terre
c'était en 1995 politique dans ce
journal une élection qui s'annonce sous
tension en octobre prochain les
républicains et des yvelines devront
choisir leur président pour succéder à
david douillet plusieurs candidats en
lice un militant jean philippe giraud
qui vient de se lancer dans la course
deux autres candidats pierre bédier le
président du conseil départemental des
idées
et également alexandra du blanche qui
est vice présidente du conseil régional
notre invité a décidé de s'associer à
cette candidature c'est pascal thévenot
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le maire de
vélizy villacoublay une première
question déjà sur cette élection de
manière générale en quoi est-elle
important pour l'avenir du parti dans
les yvelines
je pense que là on n est pas cool à
droite de se reconstruire remobiliser
retrouver un débat retrouver des idées
et je pense que ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de se tromper il faut qu on
remobilise tout le monde après un double
échec présidentiel législatif qui a été
cinglant pour les yvelines mais ils
viennent ont toujours été un modèle de
leurs atouts du centre donc je pense que
si la droite se recompose ça peut partir
des yvelines alors le premier à se
lancer dans la course de cette élection
c'est pierre bédier le président du
conseil départemental qui a donc déclaré
sa candidature début mars c'est ce qui a
laissé apparaître un début de tension au
sein de la fédération plusieurs élus
dont vous faites partie ont cosigné une
tribune pour un renouveau politique dans
les yvelines dans la tribune une phrase
forte que j'ai relevé une fédération
n'est pas n'est pas l'addition de fief
politique administrée par un baron
pierre bédier est évidemment dans le
viseur pourquoi cette cette démarche de
publier cette tribu en fête qui a eu une
démarche des élections son taux
d'octobre donc à son - sachant que
pierre qui
être candidat mais s'est présenté tout
de suite comme le président naturel et
comme s'il n'y avait pas de débat
d'autres candidatures et il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on ait beaucoup de
militants à vouloir regroupe
reconstruire mais retrouver la force de
la droite et du centre des yvelines qui
allait aussi bien de boutin à jacques
mahéas en passant par gérard larcher
pierre bédier
valérie pécresse lors d'un grand débat
est là aujourd'hui c'est présenté comme
une tension sachant qu'une élection avec
deux candidats les yvelines ce n'est pas
la corée du nord donc au contraire ça
peut donner tout un intérêt et on aime
moi j'étais surpris depuis cette tribune
du nombre de personnes qui nous rejoint
puisqu'il ya plus de la moitié délégué
de circonscription et des cadres guerre
des chiffres sur cette tribu 9 ont
revendiqué 130 élus il ya une comité de
soutien de pierre bédier qui lui dit
qu'il ya seulement 90 signataires de
cette tribune
quelle est la vérité dans tout ça non
alors après la guerre des chiffres on va
pas rentrer dans ce championnat publier
que des gens aient l'air et j'ai même
depuis on est on est bien bien au delà
de ça est par contre et on a pu la quasi
totalité
des délégués jeunes et la moitié des
circonscriptions donc ce qui veut dire
son qui sont les cadres en fait
dirigeants dans les yvelines
ce qui montre qu'il ya une envie et
c'est pas un combat en fait c'est une
gestion peut-être ancien d'hec
un chef et puis des troupes et puis une
gestion plus collective ou alexandra
dublanche partie avec magna ce trou avec
tous les beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de
moins jeunes des gens expérimentés et
moins expérimenté et c'est ce qui a fait
un peu la richesse des yvelines et
est-ce que clariant ceci n'est pas bonne
à prendre l'expérience de pierre bédier
mais j'ai ma propre expérience à l'as
sa propre expérience en plus ce sont
deux personnes qui sont allés au combat
une à la région
pour une conquête était pour gagner
contre la gauche autres menaces roues à
trappes
donc c'est aussi des gens qui ont envie
de se battre et de reconquérir mais
surtout avant tout de défendre des idées
et de reconstruire une droite et le
centre sans couper des têtes et sans
tensions mais plutôt voilà ceux qui sont
venus nous rejoindre sont des gens qui
ont envie d'avancer ils sont pas si on
aura pas de contrainte on leur a donné
envie
et quand on regarde le nombre
d'adhérents aujourd'hui
heller qui est bien il ya rencontré
énormément de gens voire des élus qui
n'ont pas renoué d'adhérents aujourd'hui
à aujourd'hui moi je suis pas secrétaire
départemental du président on parle de
quelques milliers alors que on a été
douze mille 6000 après la présidentielle
et hélas je rencontre par contre
beaucoup de gens qui reviennent à
prendre goût à croire en un futur l air
au moins dans le département
ils reprennent une adhésion donc c'est
c'est important et moi j'étais premier
surpris peut-être de cette adhésion au
delà des chiffres mais vous avez on a
énormément de gens qui les paient tous
ceux qui les élus qui notamment les
mères qui osent pas obligatoirement
s'afficher mais qu'ont beaucoup d'espoir
dans la candidature d'alexandre a aidé à
tenir
donc on va compris ne pas utiliser
plutôt le mot tension mais plutôt
l'expression de pluralité pour cette
élection à la présidence des
républicains des yvelines en quoi il
incarne justement alexandra dublanchet
othman atrous renouveau politique que
vous prenez c'est l'ange email envie de
rassembler toutes les idées tous ceux
qui veulent apporter on est d'accord sur
l'essentiel on a des vues des fois
différente à la marge et je pense que
c'est avant tout de remobiliser et de
redonner confiance à l'électeur de
droite et du centre qui a pris un gros
coup sur la tête et ça sera madame
natation comment justement remobiliser
d'ici cette élection ils essaient de
multiplier peut-être les rendez-vous de
terrain les réunions au près dans les
rendez-vous terrain les débats les
discuter de certains sujets comme
d'actualité
qui peuvent être aujourd'hui
l'immigration a que les collectivités
territoriales eux l'économie et la dette
et pour que on adhésives et on s'est
toujours intéressé aux faits politique
au sens noble et on a un grand vivier
il faut pas les décevoir et aujourd'hui
ils ont pu manger
d'avoir baron c'est peut-être un peu
fort mais une personne qui vous explique
que demain il faut que les affiches et
par contre les idées il ya pas besoin de
débattre les connaît et si vous voulez
pas ça vous êtes dehors merci à pascal
thévenot d'avoir été avec nous mais
avaler républicain de
vélizy-villacoublay je rappelle que vous
êtes l'un des principaux soutiens
d'alexandra du blanche dans cette
élection à la présidence des
républicains des yvelines et cette
élection elle est programmée au mois
d'octobre un mot de sport à présent avec
cette journée festive sur la thématique
du handicap elle s'est tenue le week-end
dernier au golf national à guyancourt
plusieurs animations ont rythmé
l'événement un village handigolf avec
des initiations notamment et une
démonstration de l'équipe de france
récente championne d'europe
un colloque était également au programme
sur la thématique de l'accessibilité
le golf est un bon moyen d'insertion
pour les personnes handicapées écouter
ses propos recueillis par patrice
carmouze sur des images d'yves obstine
berger je pense que le golf pour moi
c'est une vie c'est l'ouverture sur la
vie et sur le
l'insertion le but quand même du golfe
comme moi je le vois comme ça c'est je
le vois vraiment en insertion de la vie
parce que le golf permet vraiment de
de se dépasser et de vivre
plein de choses comment se comporter
justement avec une personne en situation
de handicap il hier mardi l' agence de
communication at-elle dit de truffes
était à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines en collaboration
avec dassault systèmes elle renseigne et
elle les étudiants et professeurs sur
les bonnes attitudes à adopter est
l'objectif de cette animation intitulée
à super collègues
le collègue handicap faire évoluer lé
regard vis-à-vis des personnes
handicapées interview au micro de marion
ptac et camille lambert
en fait on a un petit test a présenté un
grand nombre de personnes qui en fait
détermine si les gens sont des bons
collègues en entreprise vis-à-vis de
l'handicap comment les personnes rien
savoir comment les personnes réagissent
et doit alors déterminer du coup 1
un espèce de badges pour savoir ce cv
des bons collègues ont vis à vis
l'handicap où l'on travaille avec une
personne handicapée est somme toute
assez simple mais avant tout une
question de comportement si je travaille
avec une personne malentendante je vais
devoir rendre le réflexe de me mettre
bien en face d'elle de bien articuler
sans trop d'efforts pour qu'elle me
comprennent si je lui tourner le dos
elle ne pourra pas lire sur mes lèvres
et elle ne pourra pas
on pourra pas avoir une collaboration
fiable et efficace et pour plus
d'informations sur cette initiative
rendez vous sur le site internet de
tellme de truffes en bref les étudiants
de l'ue vs q votre contre le blocage de
l'établissement la décision a été prise
hier mardi en assemblée générale un
grand mouvement de protestation contre
la réforme de l'accès à l'université se
tient en ce moment dans les facultés
françaises et des blocages notamment à
sciences po paris et nanterre où les
examens ont été reportés et des
étudiants de l'ub est ce qu a justement
qui organise ce vendredi un colloque 9
mètres carrés de l'autre côté du parloir
un événement pour parler des conditions
de vie en prison c'est de 9h30 à 15h30
au bâtiment leclerc de l'ue vs cul et
nous recevons deux des organisateurs de
ce colloque ils seront en tout à quatre
étudiants en droit levé sql et des
étudiants qui sont avec moi au plateau
c'était les baralbins soir ça et où ils
freineront sio bonsoir une première
question ce colloque se déroule quelques
semaines seulement après le mouvement de
grogne des surveillants de prison il
dénonçait notamment les conditions de
vie carcérale la surpopulation carcérale
est ce que c'est ce qui a motivé en
partie est ce que c'est l'une des
raisons qui vous a poussé à organiser ce
colloque dans un premier temps c'était
plus de la curiosité personnelle qui
nous avons nous pousse à rechercher à
faire une recherche en chine est là et
ensuite ça c'est aussi un projet
obligatoires oui ça se déroule dans le
cadre d'un projet d'étude c'est ça très
bien et il est vous qu'est ce qui vous
touche finalement dans ce sujet des
conditions de vie carcérale
du coup moi c'était pas du tout par
rapport à l'actualité c'était plus par
rapport à voir ce qui se passe du côté
de la pratique de trompes du droit pénal
puisque on a des cours au pénal à la
faculté et même au niveau des libertés
fondamentales c'était bien d'avoir les
deux points de vue dans un même projet
quels sont les objectifs d'un tel
colloque
dans un premier temps c'est de faire
rayonner la faculté et ça aussi pour
nous parce que ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir quelque chose en plus
sur le cd et d'en savoir plus aussi
parce que on voit les libertés
fondamentales dans la théorie mais on
voit pas sans rire la pratique en tant
qu'étudiant c'est une chance et que
saviez-vous justement de ce thème des
conditions carcérales avant de vous
plonger pleinement dans le sujet ce que
vous saviez beaucoup de choses sur le
sujet on savait qu'il y avait des
problèmes puisque ça on le voit
régulièrement dans l'actualité après en
recherchant un petit peu c'est vrai que
au niveau des places disponibles il y en
a cinquante neuf mille en france et au
niveau des détenus qui sont dans les
prisons en à 69,8 donc en tête c'est
vraiment une porte de carence de la
société de ne pas réussir à gérer les
détenus ne serait ce pas un peu en
créant des centres spécialisés pour un
certain type de détenus et d'autres
centres pour par exemple les peines
beaucoup plus légères puisque ben on
l'avait visité la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy se déroulera demain à part
exactement comme ça c'est dans la même
optique pour amener les gens à
s'intéresser au sujet et puis en fait
dans une maison d'arrêt c'est des gens
qui soient qui purgent des peines assez
légères ceux qui sont en attente de
jugement par exemple ce serait peut-être
bien de les séparer
enfin voilà donc l'objectif du colloque
ce site proposé des améliorations à
travers différentes perspectives pour
justement amener les prisonniers à avoir
de meilleures conditions de vie dans
l'avenir mais sur cette visite vous
aller témoigner lors du colloque
vendredi de ce que vous avez vu sur
place à la maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy
possiblement puisqu'on va instaurer un
petit mot à dire sur le colloque en
début donc on a parlé de notre vie de la
maison d'arrêt et des implications des
enjeux pour l'avenir
alors il y aura des intervenants de
champ on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
juste après organiser un tel colloque
est ce que ça c'est compliqué parce que
c'est quand même une thématique sensible
ces conditions de vie carcérale est ce
que c était compliqué l'organiser en
fait c'est un sujet un petit peu
polémique du coup c'est intéressant d'en
parler justement avec différents points
de vue comme ça on se rend bien compte
des pour et des contres et alors après
ce qui est compliqué c'est déjà de
trouver d'autres intervenants ce qu'il
faut avoir un panel assez variés pour
que tout le monde soit content et puis
aussi après les contacter avant des
réponses ça c'est pas toujours évident
on est vraiment content de ce qu'on a
réussi à monter en assez peu de temps
finalement
mais je les ai diversité d'intervenants
ce que demain ça sera assez transversale
finalement ou parlerai du côté
historique des conditions carcérales le
côté sociologique et aussi artistique
il ya plein de thèmes qui vont demain
s'entremêler on a réussi à avoir des
artistes à avoir des professionnels à
avoir des gens qui sont des recherches
sur le sujet de la prison dont on voit
là qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir du
programme on va pas le détail et dans
son ensemble mais qu'est ce qu'on doit
retenir de ce programme du colloque
vendredi
alors s'il faut retenir c'est que déjà
on va par une histoire puisque on ne
peut pas parler des conditions de vie en
prison sans retracer un petit peu
l'historique
après on ne peut pas parler non plus des
conditions de vie en prison sans la
garantie des droits des prisonniers donc
du coup il y aura vraiment un aspect
assez importants sur les libertés
fondamentales et l'aspect sociologique
d'accord et puis enfin on a l'on s'est
dit que ce serait quand même pas mal
sont arrivés à faire venir des
directeurs d'instituts pénitentiaire
parce que en fait c'est bien aussi
d'avoir leur point de vue puisqu'ils
sont vraiment plus proches des
prisonniers puisqu'il légère est entre
guillemets tous les jours donc comme ça
il ya un peu tous les points de vue la
théorie la pratique ce qu'on pourrait
améliorer ce qui ce qui doit pas bouger
et puis comme ça c'est assez assez varié
et intéressant
sa cote et d'universitaires y aura par
exemple à la directrice de la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy et sera présente
demain sur ce colloque est ce que
finalement c'est une finalité dans notre
projet où ça va se poursuivre sur la
suite on en discutait tout à l'heure par
téléphone wilfried mais l'idée c'est
peut-être de mener aussi des projets
auprès des prisonniers c'est ça
justement ce avec leurs dix mineurs
normalement il y avait un projet d'art
avec les prisonniers où il allait
s'exprimer à travers l'art donc c'est
vraiment une vision qu'on cherche à
retranscrire puisque possiblement il à
faire publier et dans la publication
justement on va essayer de mettre les
amoureux d'art qui ont été faits par les
crises et une questions plus pratiques
comment on fait pour participer à votre
colloque à bord vient à la fac on avec
sa carte d'identité on se présente
éventuellement on envoie un message
avant pour que je puisse faire une liste
compte tenu de la situation dans les
universités en ce moment mais après son
entrée libre donc on vient et que l'on
s'installe et on prend du plaisir à
écouter une dernière question qu'est ce
qu'ils feraient que ça soit une réussite
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
colloque une salle bien remplie d'eau et
de lait coûte surtout merci à vous deux
en tout cas les bars à lait et wilfrid
lawrence yun avoir été avec nous les
deux des organisateurs de ce colloque je
rappelle que vous êtes entre 4 a
organisé ce colloque 9 mètres carrés de
l'autre côté et du parloir pour
sensibiliser sur les conditions de vie
carcérale c'est de 9h30 à 15h30 au
bâtiment leclerc de l'ue vs qu essai ce
vendredi 20 avril vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations sur la page
facebook de l'événement à qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran culture et cette
question qu'est ce qu'un territoire
l'association versailles image a
interrogé ses adhérents à les réponses
expose jusqu'au 31 mai au domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles est
découverte avec mélanie poquet sur des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
territoire portion identifié approprié
de la surface de la terre de cette
définition cyclo pedic l'association
versailles image en tire une exposition
chacun avaient quartier libre pour
exposer sa vision du territoire donc
parfois c'est un territoire plus tôt
descriptif
parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué
on a aussi une des visions c'est la
notion de tribus à la de la population
d'un espace qui délimite un territoire
on a aussi des territoires au niveau de
la photo animalière 150 photographies
entraîne le spectateur dans un voyage
sans fin résultat d'une réflexion
initiée depuis le mois de septembre
grand ou petit format couleur ou noir et
blanc dix neuf photographes se sont
prêtés au jeu et partagent leur vision
je fais beaucoup de photos animalières
en fait j'ai fait un focus sur les
libellules parce que ce sont des
insectes qui me passionne il y en a
beaucoup qui ont disparu si on enlève
les mares si on enlève tout ça
disparaissent et donc la notion de
territoire pour moi était importante par
rapport à elle
je suis parti du principe que finalement
faire une photographie s'est posé un
cadre s'est posée donc des limites dans
un espace et que ses limites des limites
justement un territoire le territoire
photographique dans lequel on va y
projeter un certain nombre de choses
dans lequel on va interpréter un certain
nombre de choses
c'est un territoire propre en france à
l'étranger sur la terre ou dans les airs
les photographes vous font découvrir des
trésors cachés de territoire toutes les
infos culturelles du territoire à voir
dans le 7-8 culture présentée par
mélanie poquet et c'est juste après ce
journal mais avant de se quitter une
idée de sortie vous le savez en ce
moment c'est à les vacances scolaires le
centre commercial espace saint quentin à
propose depuis vendredi à des animations
autour des schtroumpfs et leurs 60 ans
d'histoire l'occasion de retourner en
enfance comme l'a fait amicale et demi
d'euros ils ont quitté leur village pour
s'installer l'espace saint quentin un
atelier sur les schtroumpfs est
programmé place des pyramides
une thématique qui a permis au centre
d'attirer 30 % de visiteurs
supplémentaires par rapport à l'année
dernière de faire venir le strophes nous
permettait de venir partager une émotion
autour d'un personnage
transgénérationnel et donc dans notre
animation par exemple qui a démarré au
samedi au vendredi de la semaine
dernière on a des enfants qui
participent à la nao aux activités ou
même des personnes de plus de 60 ans
c'est ce qui est génial
au programme des quiz des atelier
coloriage interactif mais également une
exposition inédite qui retrace
l'histoire des petits hommes bleus et de
son créateur
cette année
60 ans des schtroumpfs voilà on a une
tournée européenne donc et sur la france
la belgique et la suisse retrouve donc
tout les soirs des schtroumpfs donc
l'histoire de peyo qui est le
dessinateur principal ce mercredi 18
avril une trentaine d'enfants a pu
tester les animations j'aime bien j'ai
fait des dessins des trous j'ai fais
tout fait
après j'ai fait rognon les animations
jeux tron feu sont programmées jusqu'à
ce samedi 21 avril à l'espace saint
quentin c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle cette information avant de
vous quitter
la grève qui se poursuit à la sncf
encore demain jeudi
le trafic sera très perturbé ce jeudi
sur le réseau des transports en ile de
france à saint quentin en yvelines ce
sera encore plus compliqué par rapport à
aujourd'hui
1 train sur 3 à prévoir pour le rer c à
7 1 train sur 4 sur la ligne l du
transilien et sur les lignes u 1 train
sur 3 vous pouvez consulter l'horaire de
votre train sur le site transilien.com
ce journal vous pouvez bien sûr le
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]